>>> BREAKING OVERNIGHT, DOZENS
OF ISIS TERRORISTS KILLED IN A
SERIES OF U.S. AIR STRIKES.
THE TERRORISTS TARGETED AS THEY
APPARENTLY TRIED TO ESCAPE
FALLUJAH.
CNN PENTAGON CORRESPONDENT
BARBARA STARR LIVE WITH THE VERY
LATEST FOR US.
BARBARA, WHAT HAVE YOU LEARNED?
>> GOOD MORNING, VICTOR.
THE U.S. SAYS THEY DID STRIKE
THIS CONVOY OF TRUCKS LEAVING
SOUTHERN FALLUJAH, AND IT MAY BE
THAT DOZENS OF ISIS FIGHTERS
WERE KILLED.
THE IRAQIS ARE SAYING THEY WERE
ALSO INVOLVED IN THOSE STRIKES.
THEY BELIEVE THERE WERE HUNDREDS
OF VEHICLES AND HUNDREDS OF ISIS
FIGHTERS KILLED AS THEY TRIED TO
ESCAPE FALLUJAH, WHICH OF COURSE
FELL TO IRAQI FORCES LIBERATING
THE TOWN FROM ISIS OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL DAYS.
WHY IS THIS VIDEO SO
INTERESTING?
BECAUSE THE QUESTION IS, WHY
WOULD ISIS RISK BECOMING SUCH A
TARGET, PUFTING HUNDREDS OF
FIGHTERS IN ONE SPOT WHERE THEY
HAD TO HAVE KNOWN THEY WOULD BE
SEEN FROM THE AIR AND BOMBED.
U.S. OFFICIALS SAY THEY THINK
THIS IS A REAL SIGN OF
DESPERATION BY ISIS TO GET OUT
OF THE WAY.
BUT, YOU KNOW, THERE'S ANOTHER
BIGGER PICTURE AT PLAY HERE, AS
WE'VE DISCUSSED THIS MORNING.
THE CIA SAYS ISIS STILL A VERY
LONG WAY TO GO.
THEY HAVE A VERY SIGNIFICANT
CAPABILITY TO LAUNCH TERROR
ATTACKS, ESPECIALLY IN EUROPE,
OUTSIDE OF IRAQ AND SYRIA, AS WE
HAVE JUST SEEN IN ISTANBUL.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU, A TOP U.S.
AIR FORCE INTELLIGENCE OFFICIAL
HAS TOLD US THIS WEEK WHEN HE
LOOKS AT THE TARGETING CAMPAIGN,
HITTING THE RIGHT TARG